From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning. It's June 20th, 2014. My name is David Cline and I'm here in Chester, Virginia, on behalf of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture, to interview the Reverend Dr. Rev. Dr. Wyatt Tee Walker.
Neglected to say thank you very much for meeting with us this morning and it's quite an honor for me personally.
Appreciate the memories. My name is Rev. Dr. Wyatt Tee Walker. I was born in Brockton, Massachusetts, August 16, 1928.
And my only claim to fame is that I was once chief of staff at Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.
That's quite a claim to fame. If I may, I'm always interested in how people's backgrounds influence the way their lives later played out.
So could you tell us a little bit about your family and growing up?
Well I grew up as a preacher's kid. My father was a congregation in South Jersey of about a hundred small church.
He was a very scholarly gentleman. He read Greek and Hebrew every day.
And his style of ministry, I'm sure, influenced me and my work as a pastor.
And he was *not* too keen about me joining Martin King and leaving the church I was serving at Petersburg at the time.
But he came to appreciate a great deal.
Could you tell us a little bit about how you did it?
Yes, I'm doing a go.
Okay, I got it.
Did you have any early encounters with racism or segregation in New Jersey?
I lost my first girlfriend because of it.
It was a little girl who lived within two blocks from my home, named Nancy.
And we used to play together.
And one day she came to the curb from her house and she was sort of crying.
And she said she couldn't play with me anymore.
I said why? She said because you're colored.
I didn't even know what that meant.
But later I understood it.
And my first schooling was segregated schools.
And my first experience of integration in education was in junior high school and high school.
And so, and in town that I lived in, it was a drug store and you couldn't be served in it.
And Ku Klux Klan was operative in area.
they burned a cross on one of the father's divine headquarters.
*It* was like growing up in the south, really.
But I couldn't compare it until later on in life.
So, and my father was a race man.
And he was always involved in trying to find some reconciliation between the white and the black community.
And I grew up with a portrait of Frederick Douglass on the wall.
And so, I was very familiar with the history of our people in America.
And I resented everything about the segregation pattern that existed.
I guess, widely, but in the section of North South Jersey we lived in and we called it Little Georgia because it was so bad.
And did you, when you were called to the church, did you initially think that the church might be a way for you to address these issues?
Initially, in fact, when I finished university I was a major in physics and chemistry.
And I wanted to be a physician.
But the call to the ministry seemed to be more pressing because of my experiences in Richmond, Virginia with segregation and discrimination.
And I saw that as the best means of fighting segregation in any form that I found it.
the Black preacher is the freest man in society because he is accountable to the black community.
And I could, I had discerned that in my early college experience.
And what kinds of things did you involve your congregation and early on in terms of?
Well, it was more active when I was a pastor in the Harlem.
We were against the drug traffic and we pick it in and demonstrate march against drug enterprises.
So I guess my interest focused on seniors, the drug traffic and working to develop affordable housing.
And at the point that I left New York, I had become the largest developer of affordable housing in New York State.
So that's a part of the legacy of my service.
It's wonderful. We'll get to that story in a little bit.
If I could focus just for a second on Richmond and your first pastor in New York.
Well, I went to the undergraduate school of Virginia Union University and then I went to the graduate school of religion to earn my MDiv.
And I was called to a church in Petersburg in my last year.
I was 22 years old. I thought I really found out recently that I was 23.
I had always used my birth year as 29 and visiting a sister who was recovering from a automobile accident.
She had my mother's papers among which was my birth certificate and my birth date was 1928.
So instead of me looking forward to my 86 birthday, I'm looking forward to my 87th and all because this year.
So in after Petersburg?
Well, I was in Petersburg eight years as a pastor at the Gillfield Baptist Church which is over 200 years old.
And I went to New York and joined the corporate world.
I was in a publishing firm. I was a marketing director.
And then I went to I was called to a church in Harlem and I served there for 37 years.
And it was a wonderful ministry and the way I responded to my leadership.
Can I ask you about an early incident with a library?
Was that here in Richmond?
Yes, in Petersburg. Can you tell us a little bit about that?
Yes. Of course, everything was segregated in Petersburg when I arrived, including the ministerial alliance.
And the first experience I had in integrating was integrating it with the Chaplain of Virginia State.
And another pastor in the town, RG Williams.
We integrated the ministerial alliance.
And about eight years later, I tried to get the city council to integrate the library and they would not even consider it.
And for some reason, the N. W. C. would not make a case of it.
And I felt they had pulled a rug from under me.
So I influenced the gang by King.
I had a demonstration.
And we went there on February 27th, 1960.
And we went through the white door, which we were promptly arrested in a few minutes.
And two of us, (Rev.) R.G. Williams + I (Walker), the two of us decided to stay in jail.
We stayed in jail a couple of days.
And of course, that was back in that day.
That was big news.
And unusual because the black community in Petersburg had been so cowed by the system of segregation.
They wouldn't even think of trying to integrate a facility.
And it happened that it was the first time the library had been desegregated in the South.
Do you remember what book it was that you...
Yes, I do.
I asked for a volume one of Douglas Elvall Freeman's biography of Robert E. Lee.
I always thought Lee was guilty of treason.
And I just thought I'd look at this book to see what the Southern view was.
Why they made him such a hero.
Did anybody comment on the fact that you would check out Lee's biography?
I've seen several articles about it, the how I asked ironically for that book.
And that led to my arrest.
And did you already know Dr. King at that point?
Or at what point did you get to know him?
In 19...
It must have been 1952.
And I joined his organization and he put me on the board.
And I did some writing for him in press releases because I had that set of skills.
And so I've been close to him since 1952 until his death.
In fact, the day before he was assassinated, he had called my home.
And wanted to talk to me about something.
I don't know why.
I have always imagined that he wanted me to come to Memphis to help with the march that had gone wrong the day before.
But you know, I just don't know.
But he had a great influence on my life.
When I went to Petersburg as a pastor, I carried a Smith & Wesson nickel-plated .32.
And Martin Luther King's influence, I put my gun down.
I was waiting for some racist to cross my path.
And I had in my mind that I had *his (father's) pistol, [to] shoot him*.
And I got that idea from my father who was in a train station somewhere near Norfolk, Virginia.
And it was cold and he went in the so-called weight waiting room.
And the constable came in there and told him he had to leave.
The father told him he was too cold.
And the constable raised his hand.
His night stick to hitting.
My father said he had his coat on and his trigger on the gun.
And he said, *by the time it* started down.
He was going to shoot him.
And so from the very beginning, my father's early life to my early life.
That's why I say I know he was a race man.
And I'm sure I inherited some of that.
So was the concept of non-violence and practicing non-violence?
No, it wasn't in Vogue at that time.
So did that take some training and get him used to that idea for you?
Well, I took a lot of reading and hearing King over and over again.
Seeing his commitment to non-violence made me adopted it as a way of life.
But all through college, I envisioned putting together some smart young black man
who developed the expertise in using plastic bombs
and putting, I speak through the opponent's ears like (Theodore) Bilbo and (James) Eastland.
And that was what I fantasized during my college years.
And then I end up as Dr. King's right hand man in non-violence.
So life has its quirks and turns.
So you began working on the board when were you first called to actually join the organization?
Well, he invited me to the initial meeting in Atlanta, but I didn't have enough money to go.
And so I didn't join the SCLC until the meeting in Clarksdale, Mississippi in 1958, I think it was.
And that's when he put me on the board and I began to work close to him until his death.
And when you came on as a staff member, that was 1960.
He invited me to *become* Executive Director of the organization to help build it
into what became the, in my view, the most powerful civil rights organization in the 60s.
You came in after Ella Baker?
Oh, absolutely.
Yes.
She was the interim executive director, but I was after her.
I knew her from an earlier experience, but that was after the fact.
And what was the situation with the organization when you first arrived?
And how did you manage to grow it over?
Well, it was, I used to describe it as mainly an idea in Dr. King's briefcase.
And trying to connect churches and passages of former Rubo Task.
And I just, I flew by and just see to my parents as they say.
And I put a fundraising system in.
The budget, my first year was $57,000.
We did over 100,000.
And in four years, when I went, I took two members with me from my staff in Petersburg.
And that made SCLC a five staff member because they were two working here.
And when four years later, we had a budget of $1,000,000 and a hundred full-time employees.
So I worked primarily as administrator and a fund raiser.
And there were some way stations along the way, but things didn't really start popping until Albany and Birmingham.
Before we get to Albany, I just want to ask you talking about money.
How important was money to the success of the company?
It is the ammunition.
But you know, it takes money to run an organization and to run campaigns and to train people.
And that's what we needed the money for because non-advance was an altogether novel concept in 1960 and in 1961.
And we developed it into a driving force which changed the nation in a way.
It was responsible for desegregating America.
Of course, the movement in the streets has received to be really driving this change.
And it's a huge part of it, but there's so much going on behind this.
Oh, absolutely.
And there were so many pundits who thought that we just decided to go to a place and have some demonstration, by the way.
We started a year ahead of time in Birmingham and that's an illustration of what it takes to do to have great movements.
We were talking just about to talk about Albany, Georgia.
And if you could tell us a little bit about the invitation to come to Albany and the situation that you found there.
And then I'll ask you a little bit afterwards how that led to your tactics in Birmingham.
Well, Albany was considered by the media and the pundits who observed what was going on that it was a failure.
But in my view, it was a success.
We just made some mistakes.
In Albany, we shouldn't have, but we did make them.
But we were just beginning social revolution, so that's understandable.
The problem in Albany was twofold.
One, they had too many targets.
It was initiated by the workers, the SNCC workers, and the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
And that resulted in the community being exhausted for fundraising and rallies, et cetera.
And SNCC realized that they were in over their heads and so they invited Dr. King to come.
Well, when King goes, I went.
And I had the reputation of running the tight ship.
And I reacted very defensively when they eliminated Dr. King to one vote.
And whatever the vote was, contrary to his advice, I thought was a mistake.
So there was some interesting warfare between the organizations, the core people, the NAACP, the local community organization, and the other Christian leadership conference.
And Louis Lomax, who never went to Albany, was African American journalists.
I said, Dr. King left Albany with his tail between his legs, you know, some remarkable, it was a failure.
And Louis Lomax never came to Albany.
Only there was telephone interviews with students from SNCC.
And of course, they had a whole new view.
The organizational competition was very sharp.
And that's what caused the Albany power structure to be intransigent because they knew of this problem that we have with each other.
And as I said before, the other thing was they had too many targets.
But when we left Albany, everything was closed, the parks, the library, it wasn't like a Mexican standoff.
But in the process, the significance of Albany is that we learned how to mobilize an entire community for a campaign.
And if it had not been for Albany, and the experience we had there, we would not have won the Birmingham campaign.
So to me, that is chief significance.
I'm going to ask you just in a second the lessons and how you applied to Birmingham.
But I want to ask about a specific person there during the Albany campaign.
And that's Charles Melvin Sherrod, who was with SNCC, who you knew well.
Yes, in fact, I raised him in my congregation in Petersburg.
And got a Woolworth grant to help finance his education.
So I knew Sherrod very well.
At times he had been to my home and stayed.
So another one of those ironies of struggle.
Now there's a story that Sherrod told.
I don't know if you recall this incident, but I always loved this story that apparently in Albany at some point in a meeting with Robert Kennedy.
And Kennedy was saying he didn't want to see any more direct action when this voter registration.
And Sherrod got so angry, this is Sherrod telling this story, that he got so angry he wanted to take a swing.
He almost took a swing at the Attorney General and he held it back.
And I remember that meeting that was in Washington DC.
Kennedy administration always telling us to put our energy into voter registration.
And it was doom for failure if we did.
It was the protest marches in the action that made our movement what it was.
the obstacles to Black folks voting *were* huge.
the right to vote was theoretical *at* best.
Okay, so after Albany and Sites are said on Birmingham, you say you've learned some lessons from Albany.
What were this? So how did you plan for it?
The *main* lesson was how to organize the entire community for a campaign.
And in Albany we had sections of the city that we worked in developing and removed the mass means around from place to place in order to publicize what we were doing.
In Birmingham, the first week of the demonstrations there, the bus company went on strike.
But we held mass meetings every night in some community for 43 nights.
It was just amazing what we were able to do when I looked back at it.
But that was the strength that we had.
And we had learned those lessons in Albany more than any place else.
Now you had become a convert to non-violent strategy at this point.
Oh yes.
But you were fond of this word confrontation.
So non-violent...
Oh, projects say yes.
Can you tell me a little bit about the necessity for confrontation?
Well, Dr. King assigned me to the task of working at a campaign strategy for Birmingham.
I went to Birmingham a year ahead of time.
And I went to the stores and I measured how long it would take a young person, a middle-aged person,
a middle-aged person to go to the stores.
How many seats were available in the eating facility?
So I was very detailed in that.
And that's how Project C grew.
And when I presented that to the executive committee of SCLC, it was unanimous.
The name was accepted.
And Project C was the heart of the campaign in Birmingham.
And led to the desegregation of America with the Public Accommodations title.
And just for clarification, Project C was the blueprint.
Can you say what that stands for and what the plan was?
The Project C confrontation that we had to confront the evil that we discerned in the segregation system.
And the only way we could join it and we had in the back of our minds that Bull Connor would do something that would help us.
And he did.
He reacted in his way to our demonstrations.
And if he had meant for Bull Connor, we wouldn't have had the TV pictures that saturated America and foreign countries.
And force the business community decided we better talk.
So Bull Connor played right into the story.
He played it to a hands.
For some reason he had this idea that we should not be able to go downtown.
And if he had let us go on the first or second march or the third march, after about three or four marches downtown to Bray, what else was new?
It was his resistance to that which made the movement.
And got us sympathy from all quarters of the nation.
What about the children's movement part of that?
Well, the nonviolent credo dictates that anybody can be in the movement.
The Al Al Hibbler was arrested in Birmingham.
And so we didn't have any qualms that Dr. King and I didn't.
And James Bevel and we decided we'd use the children.
We knew there would be criticism about it.
But the children's march is what toppled the segregation system in Birmingham.
When people saw the firemen with the [fire] hoses using them against children running them down the sidewalk,
they said this won't do.
A physician in Mississippi told his son who was my new testament instructor at United Theological Seminary, that was [United Theological Seminary in] Dayton.
He said segregation is over.
And he was very prophetic in that.
And astonishing[ly], because people just didn't see.
They wouldn't accept treating children that way.
And the power of those images.
How did you develop a sense of how these using the media in such a way to help your colleagues?
We did that with great premeditation.
We wanted to get on three or four minutes on a *Huntley-Brinkley* report.
And so we, I guess I was responsible.
I told Dr. King when he said to me,
you got to find some way to dramatize our situation.
And we were late with one of our demonstrations.
And instead of marching at two, they marched at four.
By that time, a thousand people had gathered to expect something to happen.
And it was a lot of the energies with the onlookers, not participants in the struggle.
And I called the Lennon, I told him, I got it.
I said, I got it. I know what to do.
I said, I can't tell you on the phone when I got back to Atlanta.
I told him we had to slow down our demonstrations.
And so people came home and we were working together.
And Bull Connor would do something silly, which is what he did.
And put the dogs on us and use the water hoses.
We were then, I felt we were home free.
Because we *made the Huntley-Brinkley* report about two or three nights in a row.
And that was a key to the success of Birmingham, the use of the media.
Going back to the finances for a second, would you see an increase in fundraising after?
Absolutely, without a doubt.
I'm trying to think of the figures now, but they escaped me now.
But Birmingham put us, the Southern Christian East of Congress, on the map.
You knew about the NAACP.
They were outlawed in Alabama, so they couldn't operate.
And they didn't have action program.
They were not given to the demonstrations.
They were fighting the battle through courts.
And to get integration, we'd take 100 years if you just relied on the courts.
And we sensed that.
Can I ask you, if you will, to talk about the personal sacrifices you made at those times,
in terms of putting yourself in harm's way, your family, the kinds of things that you experienced?
Never thought about it.
I think we were so faithful in our struggle.
And strengthened by our religious fervor.
My wife, who was sitting here with us, was assaulted by Alabama State Trooper with rifle.
And I was beaten up on Mother's Day.
I had a broken wrist and three broken ribs.
And dislocated in my back from the batons of Alabama State Highway Patrolmen.
But we never considered it.
And we never considered it a danger.
We were so committed to the idea that we were right and moral in our struggle.
That we never thought of the danger.
And of course, we had some lives lost.
And some injuries that plague us to today.
So how did you feel then at the, I mean, at the end of the Birmingham campaign?
Well, I guess the word that I learned 25 something, where we were euphoric.
Dr. King said before we went to Birmingham, if we can crack Birmingham, we can crack the south.
And that's what happened.
So afterwards, what was the next step?
Well, we'd take on anybody.
You know, we were like the heavyweight champions then.
And for you personally, what did you do after Birmingham?
Well, I was *named* Southern Regional Coordinator for the March on Washington,
which was highly successful.
And it was an extension of our movement.
And there was nothing we couldn't do after Birmingham.
That we wouldn't try anyway.
Can you tell me a little bit about the planning for and looking back on the March on Washington?
Well, Project C, which I created at the behest [of] Dr. King's assignment, was used as an outline for the campaign in Birmingham.
And it became well, in fact, we were trying to do (likely) downtown Atlanta.
And it was the Birmingham plan.
And we were going to Danville, Virginia, which is a very mean city.
...and Dr. King *felt*.
In the wake of his assassination, maybe we wouldn't go to Danville.
So that's why Danville wasn't rescheduled.
I wonder if you could reflect how you doing up, OK, do you want to take a break?
I'm all right.
Could you reflect a little bit on the legislation that was finally achieved at the Civil Rights?
Well, we attribute to Birmingham, the Public Accommodations Act of 1964,
and Birmingham led the Selma, and the Selma March, which led to the Voting Rights Act of 1965 too.
So two major civil rights bills were the product of our campaign in Birmingham and Selma.
And they changed the complexion of politics and economics in the South.
When those past, did you feel that you would achieve, obviously you'd achieve something,
but did you feel that you had achieved what you had set out to do or there would be more down the road?
Well, as I said, once we finished with Birmingham, we felt we could take on anybody or anything.
And it was inspirational to all of the participants in a movement.
They just wanted anything we wouldn't try.
And we were convinced that God was with us.
If he had not been for the religious infrastructure of the Black community,
we would have never achieved what we had achieved.
Can you tell me a little bit more about that and the role of ministers?
Because I think it's very complicated.
Our As rallies were services.
And with religious songs, spirituals from 100 years,
or were cast with new lyrics, which we made into freedom songs.
So there wouldn't have been any movement in that for the African American church forces.
Not only the people, the adults, but the young people were a part of it.
And that's why the mass rallies were so religious oriented.
It was a natural thing. It was the connection and the confederation of the Black churches
that made our movement possible.
And then King also spoke out against some of the preacher in the Big Cadillac, for example.
And then of course, the white allies who didn't come to the battle.
Well, Dr. King was critical of that type of preacher.
But it was just a passing comment and criticism.
Most of the movement ministers were real serving priests.
Most of us were influenced by the kind of ministerial Dr. King had pursued in Birmingham.
I know that you were quite involved in typing and working with King of the letter from Birmingham jail,
which was addressed to so-called white allies.
Can you tell us a little bit about that, the press training?
Well, the interesting thing is that I was the only one in Birmingham who could make *out* Dr. King's chicken scratch writing.
And we were doing it from the edges and newspapers, from toilet paper, whatever we had.
And my secretary typed as she was exhausted.
We spent two or three nights transcribing it.
And so I did the last part of it.
And it had become the rationale, the raison d'être of our movement.
And the most important document of the 20th century, I believe,
is that it equals the Gettysburg address in my judgment.
I completely agree with you.
And are you able to go back to that moment in time when you're reading this chicken scratch?
You know, with a pencil stub in the margin of a newspaper and seeing these words emerge.
Can you remember them?
It came to me.
I recognized it when I was transcribing it.
That it was an unusual document.
And that put us in a mode of haste.
Because Dr. King wanted to see the copy before it went to press.
And the Religious Society of Friends, the Quakers, printed the first version of it.
And they call it tears of love.
I *told them, no, it should be called Letter from the Birmingham Jail*.
So I named it.
And the rest is history.
The thing about the marvelous thing about it is that Dr. King had not much to work with.
Had no library, no books.
And it was what I call muscle memory from his training.
It made such an important document.
Now, when you moved on to a career in publishing, as you mentioned, briefly after that,
what led you to move out of the daily SCLC work?
Well, economics, probably.
Oh, honestly, the Board of SCLC froze my salary at $10,000 a year.
I had a wife and four children.
I couldn't make it.
And this publisher from New York, dangled $25,000 in my face and I was gone.
And I had told the Board of SCLC, I said, you look up one day and I'll be gone.
And that's where Dr. King had seen me, Rev. Martin Luther King Sr, out to my house in Atlanta to try to persuade me to stay.
And I remember he was looking at the back window, the little stream ran through our property.
And he said, why, what are you going to do up in New York?
I told him I was going to be a marketing vice president for this publishing firm,
which was putting together a series of books about Black life in America and the world.
And he said, what are you going to pay you?
I said, were you going to start me at $25,000?
He said, were you going up there, boy?
He said, you go take care of your aunt and these babies.
And Dr. King begged me to stay, but I just, they got it.
I felt the Board of SCLC didn't, I had the responsibility of administering a million dollar budget.
And they were paying me, freezing my salary at $10,000 and I had a wife and four children.
And I used to say that I wasn't going to let, I didn't want white folks to exploit me.
I wasn't going to let black folks do it either.
And so that's why I left.
That you remained close to King in the years when you went to New York?
Oh yes.
I remained his, I was his man in New York and representative to the UN.
And I still worked with him.
And in 1967, I was in New York as a pastor and we had a case in Birmingham for parading without a permit.
And Dr. King was absolutely committed to the nonviolent cradle.
He said, after we have exhausted our remedies, then whatever it is we do.
So we went to jail in 1967.
And a part of the instrument was he took my picture and I took his picture in the Birmingham jail.
In fact, the picture is pretty famous although someone tried to steal credit for it.
But whoever took it had to be in jail with Dr. King.
So it's been no problem.
I now have all rights to it.
Some people use it without permission, but it's all right with me.
And you had been called, we're going to the pastor in New York.
In New York, yeah.
marvelous congregation.
When I left, you were 1800 members and 80% of them paid *tithes*.
And the last two years I was there, we received over a million dollars just from the *tithes* and the members.
And for a church in the center of Harlem, I was thought it was fantastic.
Could *I* ask about your formal installation at the church and Dr. King was?
Yes, he was a celebrant.
He preached a sermon, not at midnight, I remember that.
And there's a picture in my room of him putting a hood on me as a symbolic of my initiation as a pastor in the church.
But it was a marvelous experience.
And his assassination came only 11 days after that.
10 days after.
Do you remember what was on his mind or talking with him during that time?
Not really, because I was in New York and he was a Memphis.
But I always felt he was asking me to come to Memphis to organize and watch his hair for one of the marches going wrong.
And after, obviously after his death, but carrying on in the church, how did you see the movement?
If you want to call it, that playing out going forward from 1968 forward into the seventh?
Well, I felt that there was so much residual racism left in the nation, particularly cities like New York,
that the church again could be at the forefront of that movement.
And in New York, we were wrestling with the problem of quality education.
And I became immersed in the charter school movement, which was bandied about us as well as it was good or bad and so forth.
I became a central figure in that.
In fact, Rubén Díaz Sr, Spanish, passed him in the Bronx, and I led along with Rev. Floyd H. Flake,
the struggle to get charter school legislation in the state of New York.
And I opened with a fellow named Steve Klinsky.
I opened the first charter school in New York.
I don't remember the year, but it's been ten years ago.
And it's been doing very well.
The education was a major issue.
You also mentioned drugs.
And I know that you became very interested in South African politics, the anti-partner.
Well, parallel to my struggle in South.
Dr. King had been very vocal about apartheid movement.
I was recruited by people from the (South) African National Congress, ANC, John Stone, Mark Adini.
And so I mobilized churches into a 300-member federation to get the truth out about apartheid.
And I actually worked in the election of Mandela becoming president.
So I participated in two continents in the struggle against racism.
Union is out there, and the United States.
And do you see this as all connected as a global?
Oh, yes.
hatred is a terrible disease.
And racism is the outgrowth of the hatred of one people against another, usually the downtrodden.
So it is my, I have a theological position as well as a practical political position.
Has your, talking about practical politics?
Okay.
Yeah, if you could just expand a little bit, talk a little bit more about those positions.
Well, because I was involved in the apartheid movement, anti-apartheid movement, I got to go to South Africa several times.
And one time I took 22 ministers to be on the ground to see what apartheid was really like.
And the indigenous South African could not own land, could not live where they wanted to.
They had a carry pass books with the identity.
It was, it was a terrible form of racism.
It was systemized in the reformed church.
And that went from that practice to legislation.
And so there was a political solution, and I joined that.
And you said you had your theological stance as well.
Can you tell us about that?
Well, the theological position is grounded in the New Testament, philosophy, and teachings of Jesus.
And I forget the gentleman who was writing a book on the making of a mind about Dr. King.
He has been, whose writing is influenced Dr. King the most.
And he said, well, who, what answers have you received?
The day to Martin Buber.
He felt it was at Walden Pond.
Yes, [Henry David] Thoreau.
And Paul Tillich, and they named it the folks.
The other day, I don't know, well, Dr. King was influenced by Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
And Andrew [Young] said, he had not received that answer from anybody.
But more than anything else, Martin Luther King was a Christian pastor.
And it was his imitation-of-Christ paradigm that a movement got its strength and its theology.
The beloved community.
Absolutely.
About that concept.
And that comes out of the Jesus faith that black people have, and articulated by people like Martin Luther King, and Rev. Rev. Vernon Johns, and Rev. Gardner C. Taylor, and others like that.
And I continue with struggle to achieve.
Oh, absolutely.
Evil is persistent.
And you have to fight it persistently.
And when Obama got elected, the media and the pundits began to talk about the post-racial era.
But there is no post-racial era.
There is so much residual racism that is hardly changed for some people.
Let me ask the room if there are any questions.
Others would like to ask at this point.
Well, I would like to use it, Martin.
I just asked a couple more questions.
You're rolling back a little bit.
But I know.
Let's do it.
We're back to the rest of the day.
I think a question about Dr. Walker, who is the failure of Memphis's campaign.
And maybe you may want to follow up to find out what those failures were.
I think Memphis are involved in it.
No, no.
In Memphis, with Walker, who is as investing the question about Dr. King, perhaps one of Dr. Walker, who comes to Memphis.
Okay, right.
I think the failures in Memphis will be good.
I know.
I think we'll talk about that.
Great.
Any other questions?
Okay.
Terrific.
So just two final questions.
One is the Reverend List, alluding to something you mentioned earlier about Dr. King calling you perhaps calling you to Memphis.
Because of the difficulties of failures in Memphis.
What were the...
Well, the march that they had in Memphis was disrupted by.
I think they had a...
The name was the invaders, but they would put up to it by the FBI.
And so it couldn't be...
It had to be straightened out.
And I think that's Dr. King wanted some help with that.
But the federal government has been complicit again and again.
We're trying to disrupt movement in this direction, particularly the Kennedy administration.
What did you think of Dr. King's move towards jobs?
I mean, they've been there from the beginning, of course, but at that period, they're really trying to focus on the economy.
Well, that was one of the issues that grows out of the hatred that racism creates.
The lack of meaningful employment, poor schools, and not having enough burning energy to impose strict accountability.
We've seen that with the voting rights act.
There's always an attempt to dilute it, and it goes on.
So I just want to ask as a final question.
And first, let me just again say thank you so much for your time.
And this has just been amazing to hear from you today.
We really appreciate it.
And the American public will appreciate this at this persona.
I want to ask, I know you've done many, many, many interviews like this.
And I wonder if you ever leave those interviews thinking, oh, I wish there's one thing I just didn't get to say or one thing you didn't ask about.
No, my style is to tell the truth.
And I just do that all the time.
My mentor, Dr. Rev. Vernon Johns, you should say that the truth is always inflammatory.
So I'm willing to do that.
Well, we thank you for it.
You need to interview my wife.
She's the only genuine wife of one of the icons of the civil rights that exists.
And they had a book out last a long ago, a couple of years about the women of the *movement*.
And they didn't include her. It made me furious.
But she was a freedom rider.
She's been beaten with a rifle butt of Alabama State Highwayman.
And our house has been assaulted, both with guns and rocks.
In Petersburg, they shut out the lights on the parking lot.
And threw something through the front window.
And she has lived through all of that.
And been sweet and understanding and supported me, told me what to do.
The key to a long match is the husband must have the last word in his household.
Yes, dear.
Well done. Well done.
Honey, I think you were to share with them your experience on Mother's Day, 1963, before and after.
The Saturday before Mother's Day in 1963, my husband was supposed to come home for Mother's Day.
And Dr. King asked him to stay in Birmingham because someone had bombed a King, Dr. King's brother's home.
And the people were rioting because they had gotten tired of the assaults on the black community.
My husband couldn't come home, so he asked me to bring the four children to Birmingham.
And while he was out trying to quiet the crowd, the Alabama National Guardsmen had asked us to go into the lobby of the Gaston Motel.
Two of my children were sleeping in the hotel, in the lobby, in the hotel.
And I didn't go into the lobby until I got my children.
And I said I have two children asleep in the motel and the National Guardsman struck me in the head and sent me to the hospital.
I said I wouldn't go to the hospital without my children.
And we went to the hospital. And I stayed there until the next morning.
When I left the hospital, I wanted to go back to Atlanta. I was through with Birmingham.
So the children and I went back to Atlanta. When we got to Atlanta, we were two blocks into East Point, which is where the Atlanta Airport is.
A policeman pulled up beside me and said, what do you do when you see the police sirens?
I said you pull over. He said, well you didn't pull over, so follow me.
I followed him to the jail. My oldest child was 11. They arrested my 11-year-old, 10-year-old, the nine-year-old, eight-year-old, and the six-year-old.
We stayed there. Well, I asked him if I could have my one phone call.
And they said, yes, I called Rev. Martin Luther King Sr, but he had left the church. And I didn't know where else to call him.
So I called Andrew Young + Jean Childs Young's wife, Gene, and told her to get in touch with Dr. King.
Oh, they told me I used my one phone call. And I said, look at my daughter, I [should also] have one phone call. And they told me, yes. So that's how I call Andrew Young + Jean Childs Young.
And Edwina, my husband's secretary, came out to the jail. And they told them we were not there.
But they had already gotten in touch with Rev. Martin Luther King Sr. And about midnight, Rev. Martin Luther King Sr came out with someone who owned his property.
Because you had to own your property outright. You couldn't have a mortgage on it. And that gentleman made bail for me.
I had to have a trial. And they called me the day before to come to court the next day. They said, or the gentleman who had put up my bond would lose his bond.
So I got some of the school teachers to take care of my children. And I went out to the jail to the trial. And they *fined* me $84.
And I said, well, I'm not going to pay it. So they put me in jail again. But the jail was nice and clean.
And I said, this is my chance to get a good rest. So I stayed there until my husband and Robert J. Brown were coming from Atlanta, coming through East Point.
And my husband saw my car. And he said, I know my wife is in jail out here. And Robert J. Brown came in and paid my $84.00 fine and got me out of jail.
So that's what happened in East Point, Georgia after I left Birmingham, Alabama, on Mother's Day in 1963.
And at the same time, I wanted a motel to pick up her things. And I went out to buy my highway for a showman.
When they identified me, they began to beat me three of them. And they broke my wrist, three fractured ribs.
And they dislocated my spine with their batons. So it was a terrible weekend for us as a family.
But she's been very brave. And she went to Mississippi as a freedom rider.
I think we were the only couple that went. And she was in our cell for two people with 14 other women.
Did they play for children in jail with you or they in separate?
They just put us together.
They figured the whole family must be *desperadoes*.
Did anything else, did you like where I was in jail with them?
Well, just to say that she's always been supportive. And I find time, or made time to write books.
And she's read all my books before I have 30 published books. And she's read all the manuscripts before they're published.
And she's been helpful to me in my journalistic pursuits. And I now have 30 published.
And I have about 30 more to be published. I have written 55 books at last count.
I want to say one, give you one other incident that hasn't been told.
When we lived in Petersburg and my husband was president of the Petersburg Improvement Association, he was president of CORE, he was president of SCLC.
And he was well known as an agitator.
When my daughter got ready to go to school, she was barred from all public schools because of his work in Petersburg.
There was a pupil placement form that you must sign that you would not send your child to a white school.
I didn't plan to send my child to a white school, but I didn't want to sign the pupil placement form.
We did not sign it. So she was barred from all public schools.
The teachers in Petersburg, who belonged to our church and some other teachers, gave me a lesson plan every evening.
And I was able to homeschool before homeschooling was popular. I homeschooled my daughter.
My daughter finished Howard University in three years. She did a *three-year* master's at Yale.
And so we are very proud of her in spite of all that Petersburg did to keep her out of school.
She became the deputy director of the National *Endowment* for the Arts.
And she's about to retire November 1st of this year.
I want to ask one last question. And looking back over your involvement in civil rights.
Is there anything that you would have done differently?
No, no.
There were times when I used to think about getting vengeance revenge, but the Lord has moved that from my heart.
And I'm not bitter. It was the time when I was very bitter, but I'm not bitter now.
No, I just think the 60s was an exciting time to be alive. If I could have done more, I would have done more, but I had the four children, so I did what I could.
And I'm sure there are other people who know and knows about who have done much more than I did.
I don't know how. Well, some gave their lives.
Well, Dr. Walker, this is Walker. I can't remember. Thank you for planning this interview.
I know one of the younger people you don't know. *Maya Angelou* used to be on my staff, and she ran *our fundraising office* in New York on 25th Street.
Great lady.
Tell the story Dr. She came to Harlem, and you and Dr. King of the dance, he said that you were in her book.
I Know Why the Caged Bird Sings.
Someone told me a thread, Wilkinson was the first one to go on the show. She went to a rally at Manalovian Church, and saw me with Dr. King at it.
I was too young for wisdom and too handsome for virtue.
Wow, that sounds like it.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.